nervous that it's gonna be more than $10
my grad the suspense the suspense today
we're gonna try to make a zero-waste
meal for under $10 but first we're going
to busk for our money right
currently my pool gets mixed with toxic
goo producing bio waste that does
nothing to do with me or you if you know
how to use it how your motor with your
messin now that's about a minute hello
we're name nila hi we make ecologically
themed hip-hop yeah we rap about planet
Earth and specifically how to be a
zero-waste about living on planet Earth
I bring my own cup I'm always glad I
brought it a boy with my vessel I go
with my own goblet I travel with my
chalice I stumble with my tumbler I go
in my own mug so I don't have to bomb
another fill it up drink it up rinse off
and reuse good for coffee tea or some
freshly squeezed juice
I refuse single-use no excuses just
knowledge now trying to fill the land
with any more garbage zero waste is
important to me because I think that
there's no such thing as in a way to
which we throw things and it's all here
with us so I try to trash my home as
little as possible in our goings and
comments oh so many go compass so we get
cups and couplets from a Starbuck sir
Duncan's but when done with its function
it gets discarded we're done with it for
that cup is like a lover we don't love
and don't come with but a cup that's
just used once it's just a gutless
injustice because it just doesn't give
look to what the essence is Cup is zero
waste means trying to send as little as
possible to the lab though it's an ideal
that is never fully actualized but it
seems worthwhile because even the
concept of waste is a sort of an
inconsistent concept matter is matter
and
as value and so mater deserves to be
treated in a way that's respectful and
so I try not to acquire matter that I
don't need like excess packaging and
meaningless matter and I try to live
your way so that the matter that is in
my life is a matter that has meaning for
me a matter that matters when you're
walking through the coffee shop bring it
home cup when you leave it up from the
restaurant bring it all cup whether it's
cold or whether it's hot you can do with
it whatever you want
bring it home cut we're rich it's beyond
our wildest dreams
all right we got our $10 from busking
we're kind of nervous because we don't
know if we're gonna be able to get all
our ingredients without packaging it's
kind of a regular grocery store it's not
what's nice about our bag okay if I want
to do it onion okay let's go onion
mushrooms you get mushrooms yeah I have
a little bag for the mushrooms I made
all these bags out of old t-shirts so
we're gonna get the cremini through
there $5.99 a pound instead of $9.99 of
calories so I guess that's way it makes
your point three five okay that's within
budget yeah that's like less than two
dollars this is gonna be like the
delicacy part yeah that's like $2
mushrooms probably $3 now let's get some
kale I think we've got enough 1:49 a
pound and it's not that heavy does have
a rubber band but the rubber band can be
reused we're gonna get some bok choy
cutest of the vegetables it is very cute
the cutest vegetable there is like a
dollar
it's a beautiful pepper it is so what's
one thing of garlic
like 50 cents for the ah okay grocery
stores are very overwhelming sometimes
all right beans wow your heart tasty
which do you on you're on black beans or
Canelli B hello puppy it's nice when
they have bread that doesn't come in
packaging which is a rare thing which is
the cheapest these are all like 150 I
was here one of these ones with seeds
okay
the four will get tomato on the thing
yeah so we got everything package free
except for the beans which are in an
aluminum can which we will recycle I'm
nervous that it's gonna be more than ten
dollars
grab the suspense the suspense oh my god
that is satisfying with over a quarter
to spare yes that is pure profit that
quarter as 26 cents for us to enjoy our
activities we did it in 74 there's a
really good groceries a lot of food and
all it cost was summer and summer Ivan
we were thinking we were gonna make a
simple veggie and bean stew with some
bread we're gonna be cooking out of the
van this is our band her name is Kevin
we're gonna be cooking out of heaven
with a propane camping stove a pan and
we have a compost pail every single
thing here we got a secondhand except
with propane which also makes it not you
know totally zero waste are you using a
fossil fuel all of its is gonna go into
the one pan I'm gonna light this baby
all right it's hot put a little bit of
oil on the pan smells like coconut now
we're gonna put the onions we can reuse
this bowl for more things no you got the
garlic are you doing it so nice to cook
outside with the breeze and the BQE
innominate put the mushrooms onions and
mushrooms are like best friends they
like help each other cook wouldn't you
agree
[Music]
which one are you need a mushroom onion
I think so yeah I think I'm a bitter
person just comparatively yeah more
layers
and I have more sports whatever there's
two things we try to figure out who's
who
hey Joey little peppers in the van we
always have just this like spice mix
which is paprika curry salt and pepper
and stuff tomato you're on the beans
reporter cue the beans can go in now I'm
just gonna dump the whole can of beans
into this pot because it's a one pot
shop you ready for kale yeah 1 2 3
this is gonna cook down significantly
I'm gonna put a lid so that the steam
can hit the K let's turn it up last
ingredient it's a bok choy if you ever
do this at home get a lemon why don't
you make some garlic bread I'm just
gonna split up this little roll that we
got and then cover it in coconut oil and
I'm gonna put these pieces of garlic on
we don't have another pan but we do have
second hand aluminum sometimes when we
get sandwiches they come with aluminum
and so we save them
it's like secondhand clothing for a
sandwich and put it on the fire
spreading there's a good idea I love
when my meals are really green turning
off the fire everything is cooked so
good YUM oh it was great
this is exactly the kind of food that I
love it tastes like more than ten
dollars
it tastes less than like $30 but more
than ten we have at least two more
servings of this in the pan so this is
like really a 250 meal yeah yeah totally
the compost is gonna get taken to a
drop-off location there's can of beans
which is now I'm people this is
recyclable and that one little sticker
this can't be used anymore
cuz I burned it a little bit better than
now we're good when you're walking
through the coffee shop bring it home
come when you leave it up from the
restaurant bring it home whether it's
colder weather it's hot you can do with
it whenever you want bring it home cut